welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki gave us our first ever
god's eye view of the marvel timeline
but since we are gods it broke our
brains in a recent interview with screen
crush head writer michael waldron
confirmed many of our interpretations
that time in the show is all happening
at once and that the timeline is
actually intertwined strands of a rope
branches from which only get pruned by
the tva and they lead to a kang variant
cool but what and thanks to kiwiko for
sponsoring today's video more about them
later between loki and various
unresolved questions we still have from
avengers in game and new timeline
queries from black widow wandavision the
falcon winner soldier i think the best
way to understand the mcu timeline is to
break it down chronologically from the
beginning and then show how each of
these titles revise history in little
ways and by doing that historical
overlaps and branches totally change the
way we look at certain characters and
events i'm going to call these temporal
implications implications if you hate it
make your own nerdy timeline video okay
let's start with the timeline as we knew
it before in game our infinity saga we
start with the big bang 13.8 billion
years ago the universe dawns and spews
the infinity stones across the cosmos
jumping ahead to ancient earth 2.5
million years bc a vibranium meteorite
strikes wakanda enriching its soil
thirty thousand to ten thousand bc the
tribes of wakanda unite and stay the
hell out of all other world events i
don't blame them one bit then 2988 bc
thor's grandfather bore fights the dark
elves and secures the ether before
marvel studios decided it would
sometimes take reality stone form
bringing us two templation number one
something suspicious happened in 2988
because this was one of two dates to
randomly appear in the avengers quantum
computer and endgame despite no one in
the movie ever going there i speculated
kang might have rigged the time heist to
force them to get the reality stone from
instead asgard 2013 we're not really
sure it's just a weird ass loose end to
never forget okay moving on to 965 a.d
odin bites the frost giants in norway
this is shortly after he'd banished
hella to hell where at some point she
killed valkyrie's lover then 1945 the
first captain america movie takes place
steve rogers fights hydra in world war
ii he gets frozen and polar ice bucky is
captured by hydra and turn into the
winter soldier red skull is teleported
to vermeer where he becomes the soul
stone keeper now 1960s hank pym goes on
a cold war mission seen in archive
footage in ant-man this was part of
edgar wright's original opening scene
showing hank in panama in the 1960s 1980
ego and meredith quill go cruising in
missouri 1987 hank pym and janet van
dyne stop an icbm from hitting the
united states and janet disappears into
the quantum realm 1988 peter quill is
abducted by ravagers 1989 carol danvers
escorts dr wendy lawson secretly a
scroll sympathizing cree on top secret
missions carol gets blasted by the space
stone radiation she gets brainwashed by
the cree renamed viirs and this is also
the year hank pym tells howard stark to
go f himself
templation number two howard stark might
have known about the scrolls because
think about it howard was the one who
recovered the tesseract from the ocean
floor he was working nearby where the
tesseract was kept at camp lehigh in
1970 so for this to end up in the hands
of dr wendy lawson given to the skrulls
floating up in earth's orbit guys he had
to have known about that transfer and
therefore howard stark might have had
some history in the upcoming secret
invasion storyline but it would have
been a secret that died with him in 1991
howard and emery stark are murdered by
the winter soldier who steals packages
of super soldier serum for further hydra
experiments remember that 1995 thanos
slaughters gamora's people meanwhile
carol danvers returns to earth and joins
nick fury to uncover some scroll
infiltrators but ends up siding with the
squirrels to repel the cree carol
danvers leaves earth with the skrulls
and fury starts the avengers initiative
jumping ahead to 2008 to 2009 where we
started in the mcu tony stark becomes
iron man this movie actually takes place
over several months and is set six
months before iron man 2. look there are
various contradicting dates and times
that are mentioned throughout phases 1
and 2 pointed in various directions but
generally it is understood that i am
iron man was spoken in november 2009 and
implication number three something
suspicious also happened in 2009 because
2009 was the other mystery date on the
quantum computer and endgame it could
have involved tony's origin the way what
if will explore the hypothetical
scenario of killmonger saving him in
afghanistan or maybe something with
black widow like warning skarjo to make
streaming profits ironclad in her
contract 2010 iron man 2 thor and the
incredible hulk all occur in the same
week known as fury's big week another
point in the timeline that will be
revisited and what if we know they take
place all at the same time judging from
the news reels at the end of iron man 2
and coulson's plans to head to new
mexico where mjolnir has crashed it was
also later very kind that the little boy
that iron man saved at the expo was
actually a young peter parker 2011 cap
is thought out from ice and starts
boxing may 2012 the first avengers film
you know the story loki's invasion
leading the battle of new york iron man
nukes thanos attention and loki gets
arrested but templication number four
that i always have to remind people of
during this time nick fury is fully
aware of mephisto because in the
paperwork fury gave to cap to brief him
you can make out the name mephisto there
so are devil in the details from one
division truly not the only place he is
suck it haters but anyway back to 2012
in the immediate aftermath of the battle
adrian tomb's crew harvests shotari tech
and then spider-man homecoming for
whatever reason jumps eight years later
to events set four years later in 2016.
huh duplication number five sony and
marvel are different studios with
different understandings of reality the
mcu spider-man movies homecoming far
from home no way home are joint sony
disney productions sure but things that
sony throws into their movies are not
always going to be adopted wholesale by
other marvel studios titles especially
when it comes to timeline continuity so
the mcu ignores eight years later and so
shall we december 2012 iron man 3 that
is set christmas time after the battle
of new york december 2013 door of the
dark world friggis death on asgard loki
escapes he fakes his death and secretly
deposes odin 2014 captain america the
winner's soldier cat meets sam bucky
resurfaces zola's algorithm hijacks
shield project insight which for some
reason considers steven strange a person
of interest despite him not becoming an
avengers supporting sorcerer for another
two years so to implication number six
fear the out of hydra because they
either really hate surgeons or they have
sources at the tva who are leaking the
future to them also in 2014 the
guardians of the galaxy stop ronin and
thanos from getting the power stone they
save xandar and a month later they stop
ego from gooing up the universe may 2015
ultron goes online tony fears the end
game vision is created wanda is
recruited pietro dies sokovia wrecked
hulk leaves the planet and the avengers
relocate upstate july 2015 ant-man scott
lang works with hank pym and hope van
dyne to steal back resizing tech from
darren cross before he could sell it to
contacts in hydra in the tin rings
templation number seven the ten rings
are everywhere and they are well armed
soon to resurface in shanghai in the
legend of the ten rings this criminal
network has been trying to corner the
market on advanced weapons tech for
years okay february 2016 doctor strange
suffers a car accident and we know it's
february because his watch says it is
groundhog's day a clue hinting at the
movie's time loop finale he of course
seeks out commerce meets the ancient one
who had known he was coming for several
years at that point may 2016 civil war
the avengers debate the sokovia quartz
zemo frames bucky for a u.n bombing that
kills t'chaka the airport battle peter
parker says that he has had his powers
for six months meaning that fight
happened around christmas 2015 the
siberia fight zemo gets arrested bucky
hides in wakanda june 2016 black panther
returns to wakanda and faces threats
from claw and killmonger but he rallies
to reclaim his throne october 2016
spider-man homecoming peter parker
disrupts the crew of adrian tom's
vulture while trying to bang his
daughter iron man confiscates his suit
but then offers him a better one
november 2016 we pick back up with
doctor strange he completes his training
as a comitage tree goes from spring to
autumn kaiselius attacks the ancient one
dies and strange uses the time stone to
bargain with dormammu november 2017 the
events of ragnarok thor meets doctor
strange odin dies hella attacks and thor
and loki find hulk and valkyrie on
sakhar all of them return to asgard to
unleash surtur to destroy asgard but
only after loki has swiped the tesseract
templification number eight very
important to point out the events of
infinity war were not loki's fault
because there is no way loki would have
had time to contact thanos in order to
trade the tesseract thanos only found
them because he had just destroyed
zandar to get the power stone and he
only began the stone quest because
cosmic guardians like odin and like the
ancient one had died very recently loki
was just loking 32 april to may 2018
where the events of ant-man the wasp
happen scott helps hope and hank rescue
janet from the quantum realm while
dealing with ghost meanwhile of course
infinity war thanos finds he has
guardians and we know it has been a bit
since ragnarok because they were quote
22 jump points out of asgard heimdall
and loki died the avengers regroup with
the sorcerers and the guardians to try
to stop thanos from gathering all six
stones but of course they fail gamora
dies thanos snaps he dusts half of all
life and he traps scott lang in the
quantum realm and nick fury summons
captain marvel okay so that gives us our
baseline timeline before endgame screwed
it all up so in the second phase let's
look how endgame and far from home
altered the timeline in some key ways
june 2018 stark reunites with the rest
he was adrift for 22 days they staged a
comeback attempt against thanos who had
atomized the stones and thor finally
goes for the head so sometime during the
blip bruce banner has spent 18 months in
the ghana lab to fuse his mind with
hulk's body on the other side of the
blip were in october 2023 the rat who
saved the universe frees scott from the
quantum realm the avengers plan their
time heist and they go back in time to
create several variations first in 2012
bruce banner gets the time stone from
the ancient one hypothetically creating
a branch timeline very briefly without
the time stone and no time stone that
strange would need to use against
dormammu
meanwhile cap says hail hydra to get the
mind stone creating probably a very
confusing branch timeline there and then
tony fumbles the tesseract allowing loki
to steal it and escape obviously more on
that branch a bit later so instead they
jump back to 1970 to steal the
tesseracts creating another branch with
no tesseract that would have been used
by wendy lawson to help the scrolls so
no it's known for carol danvers to get
her powers no stone for avengers and
loki to fight over 2013 thor and rocket
steal the reality stone and they steal
mjolnir creating a branch where thor
would have to fight the dark elves
weapon list and malekith would tear
apart jane foster look for that ether
2014 natasha sacrifices herself to give
clint the soul stone another branch
where that would no longer be in vormer
and red skull could bounce if only it
were that easy also in 2014 roadie and
nebula take the power stone from morag
another branch where peter quill would
wake up very confused meanwhile nebula
gets taken by that heiress thanos who
then takes his forces into the future
templification number nine we cannot
forget that there is still a timeline in
the multiverse that has no thanos in it
since this 2014 era thanos and its
forces were destroyed in the present day
and that alteration was never patched
unless the tva might have pruned it off
screen or something there remained some
branch timeline with no thanos no
gomorrah and therefore probably no
guardians of the galaxy but hey the
novacor and xandar are still okay what a
bunch of a-holes but before i continue
with this kiwiko is defining the future
of play by making it engaging enriching
and seriously fun kiwico offers eight
subscription lines each catering to
different age groups designed to expose
kids to concepts in steam science
technology engineering art and math they
believe in the concept of small today
big tomorrow teach kids problem solving
on small projects today and who knows
what they can accomplish in the future
they're a great way to avoid the summer
brain drain and keep kids educationally
engaged while they're out of school or
continue the educational mindset after
school or on the weekends so this month
the eureka crate gave me the tools to
build this pencil sharpener
look at it go
look at this sharp
i feel so accomplished there's a lot of
fun putting it together and a couple
other new rock star staff members got in
on it too i mean there aren't any kids
in her office but these grown-up kids
were having a blast see kimiko wants
kids to be fearless innovators and
design projects to help them develop
that muscle kiwico now ships to over 40
countries you can get 50 off your first
month of any crate by going to
kiwico.com new rockstars linked below in
the description but back in 2023 the
avengers are able to snap half of all
life back including peter parker's
school marching band and it is everyone
versus thanos stark sacrifices himself
in 2014 gamora is left in the present
day so templation number 10 there is
still a variant gamora on the loose
somewhere in the present mcu now that
would be variant according to the tva
yes ren slayer did say what the avengers
did and ingame was supposed to happen
but she never specified if that extended
to a variant who was initially against
the avengers who just happened to have a
change of heart but not enough of a
change of heart to take a knee for tony
stark if variant loki was an end game
loose end that the tva considered
prunable folks so could variant gamora i
don't think we were meant to interpret
renslayer's line as everything that
unfolded an endgame was supposed to
happen if one of the biggest loose ends
loki ended up inspiring an entire series
but i think what ranslayer was referring
to was how steve rogers went back in
time to clip each time heist branch
where a stone was removed but that did
not include loki's we leave that there
so each of the six stones gets patched
those branch timelines get pruned and
cap decided to stay in the year 1949 we
get that date from the official
screenplay for in game and he decides to
live happily ever after with peggy
carter and two templations here
templation eleven old man cap spent 73
years in an alternate timeline because
according to the directors and later on
by loki director kate herron cap created
a branch history by staying behind with
peggy the screenplay says that the old
man is 112 years old and since cap was
39 when he went back in time that would
mean he has aged 73 years but it is
possible that he spent some of that time
time traveling because duplication
number 12 old man cap in the tva's eyes
was a variant again according to the
loki director cap and peggy would have
been variants at least targeted by the
tva for pruning the debate is whether or
not the tva went through with it but
since old steve obviously showed up at
the end of the movie two gives sam the
shield which was a newly designed shield
that had new notches in it after his
previous shield was broken by thanos
this must mean that steve escaped
pruning one way or another check out my
recent video for theories how and then
of course the following summer june july
2024 spider-man far from home peter
parker mourns tony stark faces mysterio
in europe we see some mcu returns of
riva from the first iron man and quentin
beck who apparently invented barf in
civil war nick fury works with scrolls
from space taylors and soren discuss a
shadow war with a cree and jk simmons j
jonah jameson hosts the daily bugle
avengers tower has been bought out by
someone we think is connected to the
fantastic four even more likely now that
spider-man director john watts is
directing fantastic four for marvel okay
so the timeline is obviously a bit
complicated here right but many of you
have asked where does one division fit
into all that okay chronologically the
first new date we learned about in one
of vision is march 1999 that is when
wanda and pietro's parents oleg and
arena were killed when stark's weapons
are used during civil unrest in sokovia
and then i'm gonna say it's early 2015
when hydra exposes wanda to mind stone
radiation where she sees herself in the
future as the scarlet witch why not
earlier while hydra didn't get the mind
stone until 2012 and in that flashback
elizabeth olsen looked about as old as
she did right at the beginning of age of
ultron either way templation number 13
wanda's scarlet witch destiny was
probably foreseen by he who remains if
one is magic drain of agatha turning her
into the scarlet witch was the future
that she was able to see back in 2015 it
would mean that it was not an accidental
nexus event that needed to be pruned but
something necessary to the sacred
timeline perhaps something that would
stave off the rise of a kang variant
then after age of ultron late 2015 wanda
grieves pietro with vision at the
avengers compound that he posits the
line that made us all cry in
wandervision but what is grief
if not love
persevering then october 23 we meet
monica rambo as she blips back revealing
how scary the undusting must
have been important to note here
templation number 14. monica rambo
already had some of her powers before
she encountered west view hex radiation
because monica's body scans were blown
out she seemed to be super shady about
it and she has some suspicious history
with carol danvers i will probably learn
more about in the marvels and she tore
that rover hatch clean off its hinges
there is a history to this woman and
then november 2023 the main events of
wandavision we know we are a few weeks
after in-game wanda tries to reclaim
vision's remains she launches the hex
over westview agatha floats in wanda
bursts some kids things escalate with
sword monika gets powered up it's one at
the versus agatha vision versus white
vision wanda ends up dropping the hex
and monica joins the skrulls and then
sometime in some unknown near future
wanda is in a remote mountain cabin she
uses astral projection to look through
the darkhold and hears the voices of her
sons templication number 15 wanda
witnesses some shift in reality because
she looks surprised to suddenly hear her
son's voices suggesting something in the
cosmos might have changed in that moment
the sacred timeline rupturing dr
strange's arrival mephisto ripping apart
we'll see similarly the falcon in the
winter soldier makes some updates to the
timeline first in
1950-1953 that's when the winter soldier
faces isaiah bradley in the korean war
bradley saves some of his men but gets
imprisoned for 30 years 1983 isaiah is
snuck out of prison after being declared
dead templication number 16 someone must
have known about isaiah howard stark and
peggy carter were running shield
thaddeus ross was very hands-on with the
super soldier program for several years
someone had to know about this guy and
the fact that they knew about it and
didn't do anything about it is super
up and then sometime before 2014
the winter soldier kills rj nakajima
that was yuri's son then early 2018 in
wakanda io helps bucky break free of his
winter soldier programming and then in
april and may 2024 that was six months
after end game but between wanda vision
and far from home the main events of the
falcon winner soldier sam and bucky face
the flag smashers they track down some
super soldier serum they end up
defeating them in new york john walker
is part of this kills a guy but gets
recruited as u.s agent by val and sam
officially becomes captain america
templation number 17 peter parker was a
no-show for salmon bucky in new york
because yes peter parker was in the new
york area at this time he could have
helped them fight the flag smashers but
alas so needs a different studio maybe
peter was still sore from his scuffle
with these two in civil war or maybe
that suit charger in his bedroom wasn't
plugged in okay on to black widow which
also revises the timeline in some key
ways first off 1984 that's what alexi
claimed to have bought some version of
cap and i don't think it was just a
prison story he sincerely asks natasha
about it did he talk to you about me so
templation number 18 there could have
been some other cap successor in the 80s
that does not include isaiah bradley who
not have been captain america at that
point in history check out my video on
that 1995 the family flees ohio for cuba
after alexi burns down the north
institute stealing shield's research on
human mind control that molina later
says was part of hydra's operation with
the winter soldier program and of course
natasha and elena joined the red room
but templation number 19 howard stark
might have been linked with this north
institute because yes molina said the
north institute was connected to shield
slash hydra's winter soldier program and
howard had that serum on the night of
his death four years earlier so either
he was in support of the north institute
not realizing it was helping the winter
soldier program or he discovered that
connection and that's why hydra sent the
winter soldier to assassinate him then
sometime before 2009 natasha met hawkeye
and budapest thought she killed drakov
and started working for shield i
mentioned 2009 because in 2010 is when
she was already working for fury and
showed up iron man 2. but this 2009
could be the other 2009 event i talked
about okay but then the main events of
the film take place in may 2016 a few
days after civil war natasha flees to
norway she fights taskmaster she joins
the elena and budapest and then they all
join alexia and molina as together they
all wreck the red room and two weeks
later she changes her hair and takes off
in a queen jet to help cap free the
others from the raft i mean that scene
in civil war took place sometime late
may 2016 but implication number 20. we
still do not know how natasha got away
from thaddeus ross or where she and cap
and sam were for two years until
infinity war and with scarlett
johansson's recent dispute with disney
we may never know but fingers crossed
he's still friendly enough with kevin
feige and then sometime after in game
maybe may 2024 val assigns elena to hunt
hawkeye probably part of the same
thunderbolts initiative that she has
john walker roped into okay so this
point the timeline seems pretty stable
but oh here comes loki because loki
obviously changes how we look at the
timeline in plenty of ways now
throughout the series dozens of dates
are listed on various screens but i'm
only gonna mention the historical
settings that we actually visit and
we'll start with the big bang which
based on the opening six opening imagery
and the way this series sees time as
cyclical may also be the universal big
crunch then 79 a.d that was the
destruction of pompeii briefly
interfered with by loki this would have
caused the nexus event but the
apocalyptic nature of mount vesuvius's
explosion cleared it but then we're
going to get to pre-965 a.d but
alternate this is when young sylvia was
arrested by the tva from asgard and she
told loki in episode 6 that she was
pruned before he was born which was in
the year 965 but that line didn't make a
lot of sense to a lot of us unless you
consider templation number 21 the
timeline is actually composed of
infinite universal strands or loops this
is what mike waldron was trying to
explain in the interview time as we know
it is actually history coiling back on
itself again and again resetting from a
big crunch to a big bang with each loop
taking a different form a silvi loop a
gator loop and all the loops intertwine
like strands of a rope so silvie lived
in another one of those strands before
it was pruned an alternate universe 1549
sylvie murders tva officers in a french
church this branch was pruned by the tva
1858 she attacks more of them in an
oklahoma oil field this branch is also
pruned in 1971 loki under the alias of
db cooper hijacks a plane after losing a
bet to thor now this is not pruned since
we know db cooper to be part of our
history 1985 sylvia attacks and
kidnapped c20 at a rainfare in oshkosh
wisconsin this branch is also pruned and
then 2012 the unpruned branch from
endgame find out where loki went he
escaped with the tesseract to mongolia
where he's immediately rested by b15 and
transported to the tva now that mongolia
branch was pruned but the 2012 loki
variant is the one we stick with this
might be why loki is listed
chronologically before one division on
disney plus but really the tva is
supposed to exist separate from the
sacred timeline though the final shot of
the series did suggest the tva itself
might be variable we're not really sure
yet but for most of the season the tva
is a time-independent home base from
which loki and the other characters
visit various other time periods but in
the citadel the end of time he who
remains reveals himself as a kang
variant who scripted the sacred timeline
that orbits around him on the citadel at
the end of time but breaks at the end of
the series so templification number 22
from the citadel every second of the mcu
occurs simultaneously with every second
of loki which is very important to
consider causality with the timeline
fracturing because theoretically any
moment of the mcu could have caused that
and that could affect any moment we've
seen in the mcu additionally templation
number 23 everything that has happened
in mcu history we can assume happened
according to he who remains planned or
at least contrary to his plan and it was
a glitch he didn't get around to
patching but yes this makes you feel
uncomfortable about the free will of
other characters we've met it should but
one of those moments according to a
script occurred in october 2018 when b15
finally visits fdr high school workplace
of ravona rinslayer aka rebecca tormuny
now homecoming posters are visible
meaning this would be months after
thanos is stats so templication number
24 rand slayer survived thanos to snap
or comes from a timeline in which he
didn't exist like that 2014 no thanos
branch i mentioned and then close now
with the other dates we visited in loki
2050 the rockstar company town of haven
hills alabama gets destroyed by a
category 8 hurricane 2077 the mining
colony of lament 1 is destroyed in a
planetary collision and in the 31st
century nathaniel richards is born and
discovers traveling across timelines and
through time spawning variants known as
kang he who remains and more and
templication number 25 reed richards and
the young avengers must be coming to the
mcu while the name nathaniel richards
wasn't spoken in the loki episode saying
31st century means they are sticking
with that kang origin story and
nathaniel richard's ancestor is reed
richards mr fantastic of the fantastic
four and another one of kang's variants
is his younger self nathaniel who goes
back in time uses tech from vision and
iron man becomes iron lad and assembles
the young avengers and most of the young
avengers are or will soon be introduced
in the mcu and personally i think white
vision would be an ideal mentor to lead
it with lectures about these ships now
upcoming in the mcu will be 10 episodes
of what if that are each set in
alternate strands of the timeline kind
of like sylvie's pruning moment was that
may or may not be adopted as canon in
the future so like the first episode
with peggy carter that's in an alternate
1943-45 chongqi is set sometime after
game we think eternals will be set in
the present day and in the early years
of human civilization fighter man no way
home set we think in winter 2024 or
after and then of course multiverse of
madness is coming and we'll probably
turn all of this inside out but
hopefully this timeline helped you
understand how all of mcu history is
interconnected and how it is still
evolving title to title and a special
thanks to our editing team for putting
together these graphics they always do
great work on these videos but this was
an especially difficult undertaking i
can't bless you guys support new
rockstars by checking out our great
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thank you
for watching bye or hello welcome back
to new rockstars the timeline is
cyclical
[Music]
you